I feel like the milk mustaches you see
the magazines are for yeah I'm a
vegetarian by love very I used to love
doing tones very didn't love me anymore
straight to lactate it doesn't give you
my classic full fat white milk look this
definitely feels thicker and creamier
and do your work give it a taste jelly
time this looks like a nutty after -
yeah you know what this actually tastes
like when you lick the outside of a
peanut when'd you lick the outside of a
peanut I could see maybe making like a
milkshake with this but I'm not gonna
drink this this is more in line with
like what I think of when I think of
milk smell domine Oh this expired
unsweetened almond milk is worse than
almonds I think I mean I feel like it's
trying to be skim milk but it's not this
is not the milk for me now this one
almost looks translucent yeah like it
seems like whiter they might look at the
top you can almost like see through the
uppermost layer this is good oh it's
tasted up this one feels the most the
closest to normal it tastes very
strongly of rice I love this there you
go you know what this looks like
it looks like glue
Oh Oh that is strong this is like the
lightest flavor for me the most passable
the most like milk to me yeah I agree
definitely has a little less sweet
ending it's gold
I like the fatness I am undefeated
tastes like all I did sorry that's not
which I didn't like the milk it's not
going anywhere it says Omer Omer coconut
milk it was baked with you this one has
a handle a real big tin so I liked the
beginning but I don't love to end it was
very sick I feel like all of the
moisture in my mouth has just been
sucked out this is what we've been
waiting for already disappointed this is
great it's great and it tastes like krei
oh I'm not I'm not a fan of this stuff
this is like the loser of milk cashews
are honestly like it does upper class
nut and then the milk oh well now you're
saying that it's separate it makes me
feel better that I don't mind it I like
my most fancy right so the show today it
was all about right it was all right to
Beyonce yeah and everything everybody
else was in the show I gotta say wait a
minute here I couldn't just drink its
drink any of these straight I think I
could maybe try and corporated them with
other things
I don't know if I'd if I'd like jump to
these as a
there's any of those I'm gonna hold out
and for as long as I can deal with left
ass
[Music]
Wow
[Music]